good morning believe nation today's
message is drive emotion over to you
ASAP Rocky
[Music]
yeah I'm 26
you know I look at life through a
different point of view than most
typical rappers you know for me it's
just like life is all about vibrations
and chemistry's all about positive vibes
and negative vibes I think energy is
stronger than intention you know you
know I wanted to kind of put those I
wanted to manifest those vibes into my
music I want to do people to hear my
music and fill a certain way of
sensation even if it made you sad or
happy lifted you or even if you wanted
to turn that [ __ ] right - I'm fine with
that I want you to feel something you
know I don't want it to be blending for
you to just go oh yeah it is no I want
to drive emotion your competitive
advantage as an entrepreneur is your
emotion your ability to make people feel
the passion that you have for what
you're doing in your company to transfer
it from you to somebody else that's how
you are going to stand out because most
companies don't do that and most
companies are boring and what a lot of
entrepreneurs do is they look up to
these giant corporations that you're
competing against they feel like you
need to be able professional and so you
have a standard boring professional
looking website but understand you are
always going to lose to the bigger
company if you're trying to compete like
them because they have a name that
people recognize they have a track
record of success they've won a ton of
awards they have referrals and
recommendations they've been around so
why would I ever buy from you into the
bind from the big company unless you
have a lower price and that is the worst
business model to be in as an
entrepreneur you do not want to be in
the low price business it's going to be
a race to the bottom because it's always
going to be somebody who will undercut
your price as long as that person comes
in you're out of business your customers
will leave you because they only were
with you because of the price and so the
way to stand
the way to win as the little guy going
up against the big guy is your story is
your ability to convey emotion let me
see your passion for what you're doing
because I feel that if you are
passionate about your work I'm going to
get a better result working for you I
feel like this person really cares about
performing for me they'll given me a
great experience where some giant
corporation doesn't care I remember I
had a caller calling on my radio show
and they were in the landscaping
business and they were frustrated that
they were losing business to university
kids and high school kids who were
charging minimum wage to do landscaping
services and he was having a hard time
standing out because he was you know
three four times the cost said well why
did you start this business - because
this was really important to me when I
grew up I was always outside with my mom
and she was teaching me about how to
take care of Avalon of the outdoors and
here's the line I got me this is the
line the gum every time I go to a
customer's house I treat it like it was
my mom now I feel something towards this
person now I have a reason to buy that
needs to be everywhere when I visit that
person's website I need to see that
message I started this business as a
tribute to my mom and here's what we did
growing up and every time I come to your
home I treat it like it's my mom do I
get that same vibe if I'm going with a
college university student do I get that
same vibe with my hiring some big
company that has you know a huge crew
that they're just sending people out
this is why I'm going to pick you
because of your story and your ability
to convey that emotion to me and I'm
willing to pay more for that I'll pay
three times what you'll pay a college
student to do it because I feel like
you're going to do a better job and no
matter what you write on your website
you can write we do the best job in the
industry guaranteed everybody's putting
that on their website it means nothing
but that story is something that only
you can put out this is your competitive
advantage you better have a good story
if you're starting this business and you
don't have a deep passion or
actually what you're doing forget about
it go do something else you have that
deep passion connection then let me feel
it
share it with me tell me put it in your
content have a video if you're
comfortable enough to do it but worst
case at least have a picture in your
story and don't worry about it just
being super professional because you're
going to lose when you can drive emotion
and connect to your customer that's when
you start to win so the question today I
want you to get a little bit of practice
I want you to tell me why this business
is so important to you why did you start
this company why are you so passionate
about what you want to do why practice
right now is your chance to start
conveying some emotion to me and the
rest of the leaf nation leave it down
the comments below and we'll join in the
discussion finally what to give a quick
shout out to her mention premier Humana
- thank you so much you're picking up a
copy of my book your one word and
sharing that YouTube video button as
well
I really really appreciate the support
and hope you are enjoying the book thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
I believe Nations thank you so much for
watching if you want to learn more about
this subject get a little bit deeper on
it I'm going to share some extra bonus
clips that I hope you'll enjoy well when
I was younger about with a 16 17 18 19 I
was more creating worlds and characters
and you know I would read a lot it like
just because we like him to learn I
would read about certain people and then
just try to get in their head and see
what how they were write a song and then
now I kind of just write about my life
like I have a song called hair blows on
the new album that's just talking about
I like when his girl hair blows in the
car and that I wrote that because I was
with a female friend of mine and we were
in my car and she was hanging out the
sunroof and her hair was blowing and I
felt like the man and I wrote a song
about it and um I think a lot of artists
kind of mess up because you don't know
much about them after a certain point in
time so I try to just I realize none of
my music will sound the same if I just
write songs but actually about my life
is two years it should not be in the
same same place you what it does take
some courage though to be still
transparent about your own a lot of
people aren't honest clear they're not
comfortable with themselves that's right
so that's why you have a bunch of songs
about the same things on the radio
because one that's comforting to the to
a simple listener and two people just
aren't comfortable with themselves
they're not easy they're not if I was
like hey I'm depressed you'll be like
wow but because a lot of people won't be
able to do that or tell you what they
like and stand for it and why they won't
like it
and that goes again with a lot of people
being closed-minded
here's the thing though people see you
on stage they see on tour for years we
know you do well yeah I'm just
documenting but I try to get on lookers
fans listeners to understand that
there's no difference and it's necessary
in people now so we all have the same
emotion same emotions we all go through
the same issues and even though you see
tec-9 on this show for in the morning
you might feel more some award show
stage yeah behind closed doors yeah man
he's experienced the same thing your
neighbor might be experienced you know
yeah right and that's how we make fans
man you know Sam wheat brings us down to
on a level playing field you know me
because they look at us elevated on my
stage they automatically looking up so
when you tell them I'm having a bad day
because my people are turning on me and
I thought these people were real it
brings us on a level playing field
they're like he feels just like me you
know saying how we make fans you know
send I tapped into emotions yeah and a
lot of my fans know about my life
because I put it in my records you know
what I mean to where the wife you said
when this rain came out or well she
didn't like that you know Sam back then
but this ring is like the best song I
ever wrote pain works you mean so when I
when I did the song I love you but you
said don't write nothing else about me
if it ain't positive and I said okay
my little girl rainbow said that she
don't like me to do the lewd stuff on
stage I would do like seven words the
song seven words and lay in between the
ladies you know so I stopped that you
know I'm saying it's like I do what they
say you know sandy to the ladies but I
take care of you know I'm saying and
Alicia she's just she's 22 now man she's
out there and Oakland man just having a
wonderful time doing broadcasting and
everything she don't have too many
problems yeah yeah rainbow I can't
really talk about what's going on with
my little one because she don't want to
perceive if she got sick man and I just
like God why me mm-hmm you know I'm
saying she's probably like God why me
yes and my mama was sick all those years
and now my youngster you know saying
it's like damn but in the midst of all
that we still have time to give
ourselves to our fans people that want
to hear because it's a blessing for
people to want to hear anything yeah
especially these days been in the game
as long as I've been you know I mean is
it's like it's such a blessing that they
still want to listen and I'm I'm gonna
forever have these stories to tell
because I'm right in my life and that's
what I chose to do back in the day when
Quincy generals told me write what you
know and people will forever feel you
damn
yeah tec-9